People with post traumatic stress disorder or PTSD experience many intrusive
symptoms that last at least one month. These include things such as recurring
intrusive thoughts, feelings or memories of the traumatic event. This can
happen while awake or while dreaming. A person may experience flashbacks, which
are vivid reactions that a person feels when they're experiencing the traumatic
event over and over again. People with PTSD are easily startled, with hair
trigger tempers. They may also be reckless or self-destructive. PTSD can occur
in both children and adults. And as we discussed in lesson six, many veterans
experience PTSD. In fact, some research shows that approximately 24% of war
veterans will experience PTSD. These veterans are also at greater risk of
developing major depression, drug abuse and suicide after returning home. The
death and despair of war induced PTSD is seen in a suicide note from an Iraq
war veteran. In 2007, Daniel Somers was diagnosed with a traumatic brain
injury, post-traumatic stress disorder, Gulf War Syndrome, fibromyalgia, and a
host of other medical problems. He sought treatment through therapy,
medication, music and film production. But eventually took his own life June
10th, 2013. He left behind a powerful suicide note. Here's part of what it
said. All day, every day a screaming agony in every nerve ending in my body. It
is nothing short of torture. My mind is a wasteland filled with visions of
incredible horror, unceasing depression and crippling anxiety. Thankfully there
are treatments available for PTSD which we're going to talk about in our next
lesson.